[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu envie d'y
aller une femme oui d'une certaine façon
ça m'est arrivé
vous avez déjà violé une femme non je
serais incapable de fuir parce que ça
m'est pas venu valider sa femme c'est
marrant le viol la violer et non par de
la violer n'ont certainement pas d'avoir
dépensé faire des choses qui sont les
violeurs d'après vous
il est traqué certainement les gens
refoulé
uniquement
pense pas que quelqu'un l'équilibré
pense à violer une femme du petit pont
manque personnes qui sont pas normales
vous avez déjà violé des femmes
oui
est ce que tous les hommes sont des
violeurs en puissance
c'est possible c'est pas sûr et qui sont
les femmes qui s'est pas violer
celles qui sont imprudents
les aguicheuses ça dépend de leur tenue
je crois vestimentaire c'est leur façon
d'afficher prêter les passants qui font
qu'ils se font violer
dépôt faye coin qui sont les serveurs
celles qui veulent bien tu sembles kaki
majeure n'est prévue en libye qu'il a
déjà alalala des mariés ou étudiants
un homme déjà une fois la décadence x
lion peut plus y aller on sent trop
précis est ce que les femmes qui se font
violer l'ont provoquée d'actes non je
pense pas
18 qu'elle était consentante y arriver
un moment où elles sont consentants il
fonde une femme soit consentante pour
être violée est-ce qu'on peut violer une
femme sans son consentement
ça doit pouvoir arriver parce qu'ils y
avoir une question de force physique et
qui doit jouer je pense oui vous ne voit
pouvoir les violer on ne va pas pouvoir
les violet pour la violer omark je vous
dirais bien la technique pour les
violets n'ont qu'à la renverser ouais
mais tout ce déficit le dernier jeune
femme quand elle ne veut pas un ce sont
des femmes qui ont envie de façon
certaine à 13 heures quand une femme dit
qu'elle s'est fait violer est-ce que
vous la croyez pas toujours
c'est toujours quelqu'un qui est
consentant pas vraiment toujours mais la
réaction qui consiste à douter
systématiquement de leur réponse mon
avis n'est pas n'est pas fondée non plus
car le vrai viol existe bel et bien
vial à proprement parler c'est les
initiateurs où il faut vouloir ou
voilà on dit une femme se trouvait seul
par conséquent elle l'a cherché
comme s'il n'était pas naturel qu'une
femme puisse se trouver seul quelque
part eq automatiquement dans ces cas là
elles sont obligées de risquer un viol
non est ce que toutes les femmes ont
envie de se faire virer
je pense oui sincèrement oui on dit
qu'il ya un dixième ou un centième ou
peut-être un millième des personnes
enfin des violeurs qui sont pris parce
que les femmes n'en parle pas je pense
que c'est beaucoup plus un problème de
société et de rapports sur en fin de
rapport à la vie sexuelle et d'une
certaine liberté
dans la soirée du plan tarp
[Musique]